[Musique]
la victime dont identifier le sexe
féminin
les cinq plaies par armes blanches etc
ont été donnés de manière désordonnée à
bout portant
qui est chargée de l'enquêté
maigret brigade criminelle 36 quai des
orfèvres
quelqu'un a voulu faire disparaître
cette jeune fille inconnue mais elle a
forcément laissé des traces là quelque
part
comment vous faites pour qu'ils parlent
d'un suspect
rien je les écoute moi le voit le
chercher ce que la peur de la vérité
nous intéresse vraiment que je vous
raconte ma vie ta m'aide un peu à
comprendre une fille comme toi elle
s'appelait louis pourquoi mais vous dire
ça plaît
j'ai entendu une auto s'arrêter
concentre toi sur les chauffeurs de
taxis sur tout ce qui fonde la nuit
c'est pour la fille morte que vous
faites tout ça
il faut se protéger ne pas être à
sensible quand on perd son enfant perd
tout
il n'y a plus rien vous savez je suis je
suis
[Musique]
mais dieu à la langouste au musée depuis
de forger une carapace
puis un jour au dso déjà faire bagdad
ne touchez pas un détail alors tous tes
certitudes s'effondre d'un coup
[Musique]